so
uh welcome to session six of classic
metal class
i've got my friend and special guest
scott truly
here with me as always and we're going
to be talking about
ethical issues having to do with
farewell tours and what i think we
should probably call post farewell
tours that is tours beyond the original
farewell her is there is there an
ethical issue or set of issues there
uh i think that there is and one of the
people who
uh has been most vocal and i would say
consistent about this
is dee snyder of of twisted sister
twisted sister themselves did a farewell
to her
and snyder said this is it we're not
doing any comebacks
after this and he has he's had some
harsh words to say
about bands that have come back from
that so we're going to look at
um some of the things that he has to say
because he's not just grousing about it
there are some like serious um
well-thought-out claims that he's making
he has some
arguments that that pertain to ethics
they're not articulated
in terms of academic treatments of
ethics but i think they hit at a
core level and and i think part of this
will help us get to
a bigger topic that we might approach
later on
which is what is the what is the
relationship
between the band and the audience the
fans
you know this is a perennial issue is it
is it sort of just well the band is just
you know there and then the audience
they're the appreciators and the band
gets to do whatever the hell they want
i don't think so i i mean there are some
bands who behave that way but
i i think that there's arguably
especially when we're talking over
decades of supporting the band and
playing their music and like championing
them with other people
there's a kind of relationship that
builds up and it's it's paradoxical
because
obviously if you're a
you're a player in a major uh heavy
metal band you can't like engage
every single audience member all right
and answer every bit of fan mail that
comes to you
that's just impossible right but there's
there's something you can't just brush
people off either
say well you're just dollar signs to me
so
there's there's that bigger issue in the
background but then we're going to
consider
a lot of arguments for and against
doing tours past the original tour and
we're going to look at some uh
interesting
examples and i've got some some quips
and quotes here from people but i i've
already talked a little bit let me let
scott get in here and
and give some of his thoughts about uh
post
farewell tour obviously not an issue for
for us
right because we're we're still pretty
young right
and we're not going on tour right now
anyway but uh i mean would you would you
ever consider
doing let's say you were a music you
know in a like a super group
right and you got all these people you
put together and let's say you're
you're the band leader and you're you're
like um
i i really want to have this band and
it's and it's a super group that works
and then people other than people get
get um
tired of it or sick and you're like ah
yeah we do need to hang it up i gotta
get to
some other projects you do it farewell
to her you announce it
you know everybody's showing up they're
like we love you
you know come back again would you ever
consider
coming out of retirement and putting the
band back together and going back on
tour
no i mean i think in the first in the
first place
i wouldn't um unless there were like
dire circumstances with somebody in the
band
i would never announce a farewell tour
i'd probably
do the tour um and then um
and then you know you don't do it again
the second you announce a farewell tour
you you're essentially
making a verbal contract with your fans
okay
because now if i say farewell tour i
could jack the prices of my tickets up
i could jack the merch prices up and i
can have exclusive merch
this you can have this and you know with
ebay
people might buy up 10 of these t-shirts
and say i'm gonna keep one and sell nine
for triple the price
so now you've got money coming in um so
just the farewell bit and uh you know
kiss is an example of somebody that
would do that
um you know you know for better for
worse but you'd never imagine they would
but what you wouldn't once you announce
a farewell like this is it
i i if i did that um i wouldn't come out
of retirement with the band i'd still
make music in other forms maybe i'd form
a new band
unless it was like i'm retiring which is
all different thing but
um i think being on both sides of the
coin with this it's kind of like
uh as a fan i would say wait a minute
we had talked about this before it's
like i cancelled
two you know big pain gigs to drive all
the way to new york city
to see this it cost me this much in gas
you know i had to sit in traffic
and i would have never done it if you
didn't say it was a farewell tour for
you coming back
yeah it was was just kind of like
yeah i but anyways to answer your
question no i wouldn't even announce a
farewell tour because
that to me that would just be like
taking advantage of
now we can ask whatever we want for
ticket prices because
the die hards are going to pay whatever
they're going to get the exclusive merch
and you make them feel like what did you
get dollar signs
yeah so it's a reduction of the fan
which is a different kind of
relationship to a purely
monetary relationship or or a
relationship
which perhaps isn't simply monetary but
one where
the fan is there to be the person to
make the the musicians look like big
shots
you know you can you can pack a a hall
that maybe you couldn't do if it wasn't
a farewell tour
that's a good point yeah and what you
know what are you offering the fan and
the
the farewell tour well like some people
might say we're going to play three
songs from every album
that's an interesting one so one of the
farewell tours that i was going to talk
about
on this and that you and i have talked
about before was judas priest's epitaph
tour
which andy and i were fortunate enough
to get to see in reading pennsylvania
and um they did a retrospective
and they've done this subsequently with
with tours
that we've seen them on after that
because it wasn't there it wasn't really
their farewell tour
as it turned out um but there was this
like well we did this
at this time and here's part of the
story and then we did this album and
this the song is off of it
it was it was a it was really something
it was a great way to organize
um the the songs thematically
you could say right
so are you i think you might be frozen
there scott can you hear me
on your end yes i didn't
you cut out you should okay frozen
yeah so i was saying that on the epitaph
tour they did this great retrospective
and they covered all of these
these interesting pieces some deep cuts
um stories for each of the the uh
songs that they were doing oh so they
launched into a few without
without doing stories but mostly it was
it was a
large kind of um this is our this is our
big
end we want we want to you know as fans
this is here for you
um we want you to appreciate the whole
catalog and
it made a lot of sense too because there
were a lot of younger kids out there in
the audience who were there with their
parents
right well that's interesting too yeah
yeah i mean the um generational issue
right the
the generation yeah yeah exactly
so let's let's jump into um some of the
some of the uh issues and
and ideas so we you know if it's a
farewell tour at first it seems like a
kind of a no-brainer right
you shouldn't be calling it a farewell
tour if you don't intend it as a
farewell tour
um and and if you think about it they're
not like making this decision
in the back of the tour bus like well
let's just call this the farewell tour
it's it's planned out well in advance
they know what they're doing
so there's deliberate decision making
going on there and then they promote it
as such as you pointed out
which then comes with certain kind of
ethical obligations i would say
they create all sorts of expectations on
the parts of the fans and
and other people and you know if we look
at some of the most egregious
examples ozzy did a no more tours back
in 1992 and that was
no more tours won and then no more tours
too
is it started in 2018 and it's ongoing
is it really the last
of ozzie we'll see kiss did their
farewell to her in 2000 and 2001
and then they did the end of the road
tour which is still ongoing
right the scorpions did a farewell tour
back in the
early 2010s motley crue did their final
tour from 2014 to 2016
and then and in that criticized kiss for
doing extra farewell tours and said
we're actually going to have an
agreement we're not going to do any more
tours
motley cruise back on tour and then
you know we talked about judas priest
they had to do
a they had to you know retract their
statements about the epitaph tour i
think there's there's some
we're going to get into like some of the
reasons why maybe you could
in fact do another tour having to do
with illness
which i think also pertains to the
aussie things as well
but you know the big issue here is is it
okay for bands not just in a legal sense
but in an ethical sense to go back on
tour
you know what what would make it okay
for them to do so
so here's here's the thing from vinnie
peace who
people know from black sabbath and so
many other uh
great great things where he's been this
uh you know studio and touring musician
he says i've heard a lot of farewell
tour announcements then you find out
they're still touring
not kiss but other bands i think the
scorpions were doing a retirement tour
10 years ago
sometimes it's the time to give it up
and actually retire because
after doing it for so many years i think
with kiss it's easy because you could
probably continue with a great show with
just a kiss show
they're not even in it and an amazing
show with all these theatrics and all
the effects and great music
but it it it's cool that they announce
it and if it's true everyone go check it
out for one last time
and then he says something else that's i
think really telling and this is a point
you've brought up
before in other things i don't think
anyone thought this music was going to
last this long
back in the 70s they probably thought
the music was going to last 10 years or
something
i don't think anybody thought these
bands were going to last so long 40
years later
or more so it's kind of sad the bands
are going away but that's bound to
happen
these are unforeseen circumstances that
come about
because of the success of heavy metal as
a
genre and the fact that bands were able
to
continue to go on on tour right so
you know the kiss thing we talked about
you and me privately but we should
probably let people
in on this um there there are plans
apparently in the works for kiss to
become a franchise
and now in your view that means they
become purely a tribute band
right um
yeah you're putting not on the road
yeah so so would people show up for i
mean video piece is saying
it's going to be a great show because
it's going to be a let's call it a
kiss tm show where kiss now becomes a
kind of
what should we call it a genre of music
kiss becomes a
style i don't know how should we
how should we market in that case a
franchise
i mean that's it um i mean
just i i guess it's a matter of opinion
because people locally will go see
tribute acts that have no connection
with the real band like i always talk
about
there's a band around here called dirty
deeds and they'll they can play once a
week and pack the house
and um they're trying to look like acdc
trying to sound like
now i don't quite understand if you
don't have paul stanley and gene simmons
you don't have kiss you could try to
find an imitator but
the tickets if they were like 10 bucks
or 15 bucks they could go for fun
but you know they're not going to be 10
or 15 because the band
needs to make money the crew needs to
make money and of course paul and jean
are going to take a cut
life nation's going to take a cut um so
you've got you've you're looking at
three 400 tickets maybe
i mean that's just a project think of
all the hands that are in the pot
yeah and everybody needs to get paid
unless these people
are so desperate to be in the band that
they're willing to work for 100 bucks a
night
just to you know say they're in kiss
um but that's another ethical issue
yeah as we were talking about this a
couple days ago i was pointing out that
tommy thayer and
eric carr who've been with the band for
a long time as replacements
for and and playing the parts of um
ace really and peter chris would in
effect become the senior members of
of the band whoever whatever hired guns
they brought in to put on the makeup
we're also talking as well about the
difficulty you know it's one thing to
play somebody who's just a say rhythm
guitarist
and doesn't have any singing roles or
anything like that doesn't have to wear
grease paint it's a whole nother thing
to
sing with gene simmons's voice do his
bass lines
and put on all that makeup and and stage
stuff you know or or to do paul stanley
so
i was gonna say not to interrupt but um
a point
just from the musician's side um
you're going to take somebody that uh is
plays music you know and they're going
to transform there so they're going to
dedicate their lives to imitating
somebody else
now i could never picture that like um i
i personally could never join a tribute
band because um
now you've given up your identity
totally and so it's an interesting thing
to see how they hold up after
maybe thinking this new guy is paul
stanley
and you know from people's level is it
you know is it worth the money to i mean
it's for a lot of people
most people don't hear my opinion on it
but you know
they did they get into music to
completely imitate
somebody else to the point where it's
like you know um
uh what is it jim carrey trying to be
andy kaufman i mean
yeah so the whole
shooting oh did we freeze
no no i i can i can still see you and
hear you
on on my end yeah we're having some some
internet
issues i think um
so let's uh let's let's
while we're on this brief digression
before we get back into
the discussion of um
the uh ethical you know implications of
of
of going back onto her let's take mark's
uh point here
i don't think many bands should follow
kiss in this move but i'm glad kiss is
doing it
if only to see what happens with the
franchise how it plays out as an
experiment yeah i think there's
that's that's that's a good point
sometimes it's interesting to be able to
see whether
it could be pulled off whether it would
be any good you know maybe they do it
and people are like
ah this is this is not kiss i don't want
to hear this right
um on the on the other hand it does
also so this is something we're going to
talk about a little bit later it does
also hit
on something that's of value to fans
which is the chance to get to hear
that band again um one reason why
i think some fans might be like i don't
care how many farewell tours they do i'm
gonna go to all of them
would be well i want to get to see this
band live
right and and uh let's let's get in as
many performances before they're all too
old
and die off
so there's something to that and but i
don't know if that would really apply to
a complete
franchise band you know uh like like
like scott was saying you're not really
going to see kiss when you're going to
see
a lineup of of people who have spent a
lot of time with kiss
you know uh like tommy thayer but
they're not they're not
kiss without the key component players
maybe
and the ticket prices are going to be
kiss prices
probably more yeah you know they're
going to be more i mean like i said if
it's 15 20 bucks
it might be a fun show to see but um
for me it's hard to take it seriously i
don't know is it is that alone ethical i
mean
when do you just let the band be part of
history that's what we make records for
their snapshots of the time so
1975 1977 the you know the
the crazy nights era and they have
documentation of all of these
why can't we just you know
watch the dvds listen to the records
because it's gone i mean
paul can't sing like he used to and
that's just a fact of life
um you know permanized by recordings and
permanence by video for
forever and um that is a really
interesting
point um maybe maybe there's something
on on the fans part that's
too demanding that we we need to have
live performances
of bands you know we're sort of
demanding that they continue well into
their 70s to to gratify us
you know but there's more bands than
kiss
you know it's not like live music is
dead because kiss retirement
you know so um that's another issue and
you know
i never got to see thin lizzy um you
know like
the original lineup i would love to but
i don't want to see
hey here's so here's a great thin lizzy
tribute band here pay 250 bucks and
you're seeing finn lizzie
well no i'm not because i was born in
the wrong time or
yeah i would love to see elvis you know
be at the 68 special but i wasn't born
yet
so yeah or or for us to have seen like
uh
ufo with michael shankner
you know so and you know you know
for them to go we're going to get a
michael uh michael shanker uh
sound alike you know and you could go no
it's it's the era is gone we missed it
you can't see you can see cheap trick
but you can't see cheap trick 1978
anymore
because that would that's gone um
and that's a fact of life i think yeah
so this is a good uh point to move on to
another little snippet so in 2015
motley crew is was interviewed and they
were interviewed about
kiss and so vince neil
said kiss had five farewell tours and
four reunion tours that's exactly what
we don't want to do
uh he says that was the whole reason we
wanted to go out on top with people
saying yeah man i saw the last concert
it was awesome
we don't want to be that band where it's
built as motley crew and maybe
one original member's brother left in
the band and they're playing clubs if we
let that happen we wouldn't be thought
of
remembered like we want to be now
that is a good lead into some of the
things that dee snyder had to say
because dee snyder originally talked
about how motley crew had gone out that
way and twisted sister had gone out that
way
and then he said so this is the
blabbermouth interview of 2017. he said
i'm one of those people who express
great frustration at these bands who
retire and then come back
i think it's an insult to the fan
especially when you pay a premium for
these shows
a premium for the no more tour shirt by
ozzy osbourne how many years ago was
that
come on seriously the kiss farewell to
her farewell to ace and peter i guess
i think that's insulting scorpions did a
three-year fair world tour and changed
their mind
then he goes on and he says i don't want
them to leave but if you're going to
announce that you are
and tell us that then you're supposed to
leave
that's a key point you're supposed to
leave feel free to stay forever
but don't do a three-year farewell tour
and then change your mind the next day
not cool me and the twisted guys we are
of the mind just like just like motley
crue
oh no really is it and we're done i have
no intention of going back i don't want
to be one of those people who go back on
their word and i hope if i do the
audience tars
and feathers me and says you know what
you're worse than the people who faked
it you made a big deal
made a stink winning fingers at
everybody and then you came back
i don't want to be that guy that people
look up to ever look up
look up there and go god he used to be
so good i never want people to feel that
way
there's a lot of points there that he's
that's a great point oh that's such a
great point
hey now in 2020
uh he gave an ultimate guitar interview
and he says
they asked him we've seen a few
important bans coming out of their
retirement for a new tour such as motley
crue
what are your thoughts on this current
trend dee ever the diplomat
said i think it's [ __ ] when you say
farewell
you know rage against the machine breaks
up that's not retirement they broke
up and they reformed and that's great
but when you do a farewell tour and you
announce this and you sell tickets
and you have a t-shirt that says no more
tours thank you very much ozzie i bought
one of those
and then you come back that's [ __ ]
so when you say we're retiring
here's a key point people now don't take
it seriously
so you know it's like a joke and i think
part of it is that these artists have
nothing else going on
and i realize that without playing they
have no career
so motley crew you know in in the past
they were they
were on the same page as d snyder but
but d snyder and twisted sister hasn't
come out of
retirement motley crew did and d snyder
is saying that is the ethically wrong
thing to do
so you know he brings up a really good
point
for the fans that um we should think
about ethically too
um e snyder made a point in there that i
really liked that he said
you know he felt the top of his game yes
and he didn't want to you know wait for
15 years till
you know i i saw um black sabbath 10
years ago in oz fest and ozzy
i thought he was a corpse he couldn't he
wasn't nearly in tune
he wasn't moving and he just kept saying
his key lines we love you
you know and um that was sad that was a
sad day for me it was just
you know you should have done this like
i wanted to remember you
yeah i guess ethically i don't know i
mean
you could perform as long as you want i
guess but uh
you know like the last kiss tour uh the
one what's going on i mean
um paul stanley was using tracks he got
caught using tracks
and he couldn't sing i mean he's a
fantastic legendary front man singer
yeah yeah like i said it's past and i
think one of the d snyder's
point is go out on top it doesn't mean
you can't do music look at robert plant
he didn't want to do
the zeppelin reunion but he did this
great record and when i went to see him
he did the new record and some zeppelin
three stuff that
pertains to him in his 70s i think he's
in the 70s
and all this i'm sorry but go on there's
a lot of great points in there you were
going to get to something well
dee snyder talks specifically about that
in another interview in the metal hammer
interview in 2016 where
he was talking about why they were why
they were ending
um twisted sister tours he said when aj
passed away it was like okay now we're
losing members not that anyone else is
planning on dying anytime soon but aj
wasn't planning on dying either
i said to the other guys are we going to
be one of those bands where members
start falling away and then there's only
one original member in the band or two
different versions of the band
touring with different lineups everyone
said we take your point now
without all five of us it does seem odd
so maybe it's the time to announce that
we're calling it a day so that's
that's one set of reasons right um age
um dying off avoiding the you could call
it cheapening of the the band name
by all these acrimonious splits and then
he said something else and he said this
in other interviews too
i've endeavored to stay in the kind of
physical shape that enables me to
perform as the d
snyder that people know and love and
that's another reason for us to bow out
i don't know how long i can keep this up
i'm still delivering
and i don't know whether to thank my
lifestyle of the gods above because
we all know d snyder is very gym
oriented right
but no one can beat gravity and i don't
want to lose it on stage so he's saying
i don't want to be one of those guys who
shuffles out and
not only isn't mentally there mentally
but just doesn't have the physical chops
and he said
in another interview that i wasn't able
to find but i remember reading this
i'm cool with going going on and being d
snyder and doing um other metal stuff
maybe in another band
but we're not going to do twisted sister
because i can't do the stage
antics running around on stage i can't
continue
i can do it now i can't guarantee that
i'll be able to keep doing it
and so i think it's unfair to the fans
to
just keep going on like that you know
well
that's a good point i mean if you really
break it down if you really think about
the transaction that's happening
um up until about the year 2000 tickets
were
above 20 or 25 bucks i know when i was
going to shows
you could pay you know um you could see
kiss for nine dollars and fifty cents
now with ticket prices higher there's an
agreement
somebody pays a ticket to see your show
and
you you have a job to do yeah and i
think what decent or
maybe that's the missing premise that
that's not in there but i think what
he's saying
is i'm not going to give my fans their
money's worth
because you know if if he just went out
on stage and
you know sat in a chair and sang we're
not going to take it um
i think what he's saying is well i could
do that
yeah yeah but people paid money to see
what you know what we were all about and
if we're not all about that anymore
well because he keeps using the term
insults the fans
yeah and um i think everything he says
really lines up with it
as far as what he uh
exactly what he values and i would agree
with that it's a disappointment
to see you know um you know i remember
just not to digress much but um there
was two blue oyster cult shows i saw
where eric bloom was
sick and i am still a fan of his rants
you know he's got that
70s blues man voice and you know and he
would give the godzilla rant and
i used to go bananas but unfortunately
one of the shows
and it's great that he played the show
sick because you know what's going on
but
i remember he he was kind of like buck
would sing some of the songs and
he kind of wasn't doing the rants and i
understood that but
yeah the day that eric bloom doesn't
give the godzilla rant or the
you know uh that's part of the show the
persona the ethos it's kind of like
oh man i was like that's why i bought
the ticket
yeah you know so i'll tell you about two
shows
that um we saw that i think exemplify
this and then
let's let's uh look at mark's comment
about magnanimity
um so andy and i saw iron maiden
uh and alice cooper opened for them
and here in in milwaukee it might have
been 2014 or so
and it was an amazing show but what was
the most amazing about it was
when alice cooper came out he was in his
70s
and he was like doing all the stuff
on stage as if he was a 30 year old
and it was oh andy's telling me maiden
was 2012
so so this is a little bit earlier um
and it was it was amazing to be able to
see a guy
who was so devoted to his showmanship
that he was he was continuing to do this
stuff
um so that was quite inspiring the
epitaph tour
when um when rob helford came out there
were two things that that kind of showed
you that he was
in rough shape at the time one was that
he was he was basically just kind of
shuffling around the stage and he did
his usual
um you know changing costumes and stuff
like that and he was doing the
as good of a showmanship as he as he
could but he was not moving the way he
has been
in more recent tours which is kind of
cool to see it's like he's back to doing
okay
2012 he wasn't he wasn't uh
moving around like that the other thing
was it was clear that he was
he was not taking pauses from singing
but he wouldn't extend things as much
during the song
and you know we saw him recently
do and what i can only describe as an
athletic performance of painkiller here
in milwaukee that song to sing it
effectively you know you could you could
tell by what he was
the the movements that he's making i
told you know my daughter about this
who's who's you know a singer
and she's like well yeah he's doing that
to open up his diaphragm he's doing that
to get more
sound out of it it was uh the contrast
between those you can see
why they would have thought that the
epitaph tour would be a farewell to her
because he wouldn't be able to
if the trend was continuing he wouldn't
be able to continue
doing that sort of stuff so now mark
says snyder's comments suggest
a rather magnanimous character that's i
think he's right i think mark is right
about that
we have to explain what magnanimity is
for our audience to me
it's it's something we're familiar with
but we don't usually call it by
uh that name in in greek that translate
is great soldness
so it's the kind of person aristotle
says in the nick of mccain ethics
who knows that they are worthy of
of great honor you know they should be
treated well by other people
and acknowledged by other people and
they they
demand great honor but they don't demand
it of the
ordinary person they they realize that
you know if you're going to be like in
the top tier you're held to certain
standards
and you know what people are doing in
the lower tier
that's okay you know the ordinary person
on the street it's not going to really
bother you that much but when other
people who are claiming to be in that
top tier are screwing off
then there's a problem right magnaminity
is for aristotle in between being vain
thinking that you you know you're really
hot stuff and you
you uh ought to get more than you
currently are
and then being too humble which is
uh also advice for aristotle's point of
view is being small sold
and so many is this this right
um standpoint in between
and it means holding yourself to high
standards almost
reflexively you know saying i you know
other people might do this sort of bs
that's not for me
you know if they want to do that that's
it it's you know it's not good that
they're doing it but
that's them that let them do what
they're gonna do this is not the
twisted sister way or the d snyder way
or the the rockstar way
in a way we could say it's sort of a
meditation on well what does it mean to
be a
genuine rock star not just somebody who
has adolation from fans
and has sells a lot of records but what
does it mean to be a rock star as
an ethical type you know so i think
that's a great point yeah mark thanks
for that
that's actually that's that's very
important actually to the discussion
because i didn't think of it that way i
think
um i think right d schneider's
well it kind of goes along with what i
was saying people pay a
price for the ticket you have a job to
do
now back in the 80s um you know uh
dawkin you see videos of um
uh mick brown just too drunk to play
you know michael schechner that was a
big problem for him too right yeah
it was this problem for him so um i love
this notion
we must have come across that word in in
rhetoric in aristotle's rhetoric but i
don't remember it
so i think that's an important thing
that people can remember it's kind of
like
uh don't worry about what the fans are
doing they've paid a ticket
yeah and you really need to hold
yourself to an
ethical hire you know it's you know
they've showed up
you know they got in their car they
bought your t-shirt they bought the
ticket
um you have an ethical obligation to
you know maybe after the show did you
get your money's worth
um it would be kind of a good barometer
no this is this is a really
interesting point and it's not something
i was thinking about before
but there there's a lot of songs that
bands have about like what it is
to be on stage and what's involved in it
and so um
you know how the sense of solidarity is
produced or
thing things like that and i think about
the scorpions
you know they have a lot of stage songs
where the smoke is coming down as a
prime example
always somewhere which is about being on
tour and being lonely missing the people
you know and the scorpions are one of
the bands we're going to talk about in a
bit because they
they have they abandoned the idea of
farewell tours
and they've got some reasoning for it
but i i'm i think it's more
band-centered and more less about the
fans as such
and more like about well we really still
enjoy playing so we're going to keep
doing this
and other music that's about like what
it is to be on stage
might be less self-centered and more
like we're in this together
you know um and and some of it like
so kiss uh great expectations
you know is basically about
the audience members being groupies and
being there
you know and how how nice it is that
that the band gets to enjoy them
them you know their affection later on
so that kind of shows where their head
is at i think you could you could
probably go through
a lot of songs about that bands have
about what it's like to be
playing in concert and engage with the
fans
or being on tour and it would tell you a
lot about the ethos of the band
what do you what do you think oh that's
yeah i mean
you also kind of have to
i think lyrics could be telling but like
with kiss
um their you know their lyrics and rants
have nothing to do with their lifestyle
for example
the famous false daily rant about we met
some people backstage like vodka and
orange juice you know
and they think about culture but neither
of them drink you know
so you know this whole thing about the
party goes on
yeah um we're heavy drinkers this is and
um
it's kind of they're presenting a show
from the early days but you know paul
stanley
and they they weren't drinkers they
weren't drug users apparently
um and paul stanley claims women were my
only drug
um but i don't know i think some of them
i guess if it is autobiographical if
which i guess with paul stanley
that song would be you know
yeah but um i mean i think the scorpion
songs are too i think they come out of
the
the experience of being on long tours
you know
always somewhere makes perfect sense you
know if you think about their their yeah
oh yeah
you know that you know when they do um i
mean it's not metal but um
bob seeger is on the road right yeah
that's a
fantastic one and then um jackson brown
has um what's that song
the piano song he does about um after
the show's over
um i think those are fantastic lyrics
and um that band uh wasted had one
called um
so long it's after this i don't know if
people remember the being wasted those
uh way yeah anyway yeah
and um they had a song called so long i
thought was like the best on that album
and it was about
you know saying goodbye to your audience
you know the the sound of the amplifiers
off the walls that whole thing and
what happens post show and how lonely it
can be and um
i i think those tunes are touching
actually if that's what you're talking
about
that's that's kind of the connection
with uh you know
um talking real about it but
it's not uh your example with kiss was
kind of like
separating the fans from the band
i think right well the fans are there
basically
just for the band you know um you've got
great expectations because
it's so cool to be here with us i think
i don't know maybe i'm just reading the
song
in any case let's come back so g snyder
in in the points that he's making i
think that there's basically five
main main points that he is
he's saying that that have ethical
implications
so one of these is when bands make a
practice and they don't stick to
farewell commitments nobody's going to
believe them
and he's saying that this is becoming a
significant problem he's not the only
person to point this out
too a number of other commentators have
said there's so many farewell tours
who knows if it's really a farewell tour
anymore
right um it's also taking advantage as
you've been pointing out scott of fans
desires to purchase
tickets and and merchandise as
specifically farewell items
you know to participate one last time
and things
we talked about the point that bands
that can't keep up physical performance
are are sticking around and by doing so
they're letting fans down
uh because they're not able to to
deliver and he
i think d snyder is also saying that
it's betraying the trust of the fans
it's really lying to them to have a
farewell tour and then not not stick to
it
you're sort of lying retroactively
you're you're saying you're making a
promise that you can't fulfill
and then of course with the motley crew
thing
bans that previously condemned other
bans for this and do it themselves are
hypocrites
and we don't like hypocrisy and dee
snyder is saying i'm not going to be
i mean if i do that you should rake me
over the coals
because i would be the biggest hypocrite
of all so
i think there's there's five basic
ethical issues in in play here
uh and and we could consider each one
separately
from the others but before we do that we
should think about why bands
would justify this or why even fans
would be like i'm okay with that
so here are some arguments that could be
brought forth that are not really good
arguments
but they can help us i think clarify
this one might be
as one person said in response to me
posting about this
uh everything's fair and rock and roll
you know bands can do whatever the hell
they like
and okay that is in a certain sense true
they can do anything that they like but
that doesn't make it
okay i can do anything i like exactly
never mind the band i can go out and
uh you know pull out the shrubs of my
neighbors if i want
but that doesn't mean that's that's a
nice thing to do
exactly so i don't think that's much of
an argument at all you know
um and and it's interesting that people
would bring this up and that they'd be
like
it's okay you know i no no problem with
it um
another is that well if and you brought
this up in discussion with me before
as sort of a devil's advocate thing if
fans are willing to pay for it
what's what's the problem you know i
mean if people are
dumb enough or gullible enough to buy
into this
and want to engage in wishful thinking
or they just want to blow their
their extra income on you know one last
tour merch or something like that who
who's being harmed you know
and go ahead but you had a good response
to that you had a great response to that
i think you should follow up with what
what you said because i thought you're
absolutely right i was trying to play
devil's advocate but
um you were right on that well i mean
people are being harmed because you're
violating trust or you're not as you put
it out you're not delivering
what it is that there's sort of an
implicit contract we're going to give
you a good performance
that doesn't include just you know
wandering around stages
and mumbling things you know who i have
in mind there
right but it could be other people as
well
um you you owe being at the top of your
game to them
um there's another one that says well
this is very cynical what are the fans
gonna do you know not go see their
their favorite bands if they go out on
tour again right
yes they can i think that's all
go ahead oh sorry this is something i
keep saying
for so many situations when you the
person have the power
to make the change let's say you don't
it's like all the musicians that
complain about their music on spotify
we only get fractions of penny well you
can't complain if your stuff is on
spotify
pull it off put it on your website and
um
spotify has nothing so if if they had no
music on there they'd go bankrupt
because
they have nothing so as long as you're
willing to do it
um so the argument there with the fans
would be
hey fans if you don't want to be
exploited don't go and see
bands after their farewell tour well
that's true but it's kind of
when i asked that question you would i
kind of came up with the example i guess
that's right like those
those con artists that go after um the
elderly where they call
me now or we're going to give you this
now
the person that got conned might not
know they got conned and they might be
just as happy
it does not mean that the person that
conned them out of money
wasn't unethical right yeah so i think
you pee people going to the show um
i don't know if khan is a fair word if
that's an inflammatory word
um i think i have to get like a
particularly bad performance
in order to justify that but there may
have been cases like that you know
well you know just going back out on
tour and it's kind of like i wonder if
they're on the tour bus on their
farewell
tour going we'll wait three years and
then we'll do this again
i mean that'd be interesting yeah oh
mark has a good point here i think
of it in terms of the violation of
informed consent
fans can't consent to what they're
purchasing if they're misinformed so
in being told that this is a farewell to
her
we're never going to do another one
after this the fans are being
misinformed about what's what's going on
well i think it's fine to buy tickets
for the farewell tour
but i guess the question is if it's
their third
farewell um
you know it's you know i i guess it's
like well you could be a stick in the
mud and
protest or you could go have fun at the
show it's still an
ethical i think yeah it's kind of funny
because the more farewell tours that you
do
given that you're going to die sometime
the greater the odds are for any one
farewell tour than it truly is the last
farewell tour
right well you know that's why i say
just tour
until you don't come back um
is i'm making a big deal about it um
um i was going to make a point i i
forget to continue sorry
well so i think that you know we could
make some distinctions where
i think it could be okay to come back
from a fair farewell tour
and so you know what are the things that
cause bands to stop touring i think we
can break it down into a number of
different things one is like conflict
within a band
where they they just can't get along and
they have to they have to break up or go
on on hiatus and it could be because
some of the band members are struggling
with like addiction or personal problems
or you know midlife crises or things
like that
so that might put a band on on hold for
a while right
um the realization that it's just too
much that the band is
is too old um that could be something
that could could end it
death or incapacitation of key bandmates
i mean it's one thing if you lose
somebody who hasn't been with the band
for a really long time and isn't
integral
to the sound but if you know if iron
maiden loses steve harris
i don't think they come back from that i
don't think they're iron maiden even if
they
they go ahead oh no i'm sorry i i just
said i was going to ask you would you
buy a ticket to see our
maiden without steve harris um
i think probably not
i agree i agree i think i would waver
because i would still want to support
the band
and and it's not as if like it's not
like uh say wasp right
where wasp is at this point blackie
lawless and whoever he hires to work
with him
they've had some great you know like
randy piper and chris holmes they've got
some great guitarists
i can't remember a single drummer from
wasp
so i don't think that the drummer has
made a huge impact
um and and you know i couldn't tell you
off the top of my head who's playing
with him right now
um if if blackie wallace goes there is
no wasp
iron maiden i mean you know dave murray
and adrian smith
really talented players you know bruce
dickinson uh
nickel mcbrain you know um
and i had a hard time in the 90s with
when adrian smith
left i had a very hard time because i
thought
the contrast between dave murray and
adrian smith was so
fantastic yeah and then and then it
cares to replace him yeah
then you know ionic was um
he played too much like dave murray but
not as good as dave murray i don't think
so
you know when you heard the live stuff
it was kind of like well i could tell
that's dave murray because it's executed
better but the style's the same
yeah um when it was adrian smith
you know the next guitarist would come
in and you'd be psyched because of style
difference you know adrian's
melodic bluesy thing yeah yeah and um
so you know i'm also a big adrian smith
and i think he's a really important part
of the band
with his backup vocal and um
you know in his writing you know wasted
years is a great one but he's yeah
you know steve harry's the main writer
but but
really so that's a really tough one you
know maybe iron maiden couldn't be
franchised in the way that we're talking
about kiss being fragile i was just
going to say would you go see a
franchise iron maiden
no i mean that's an iron man tribute
band yeah
you want i mean look bruce dickinson
keeps his health up he gives us
our money's worth every time i've seen
them i get my money's worth when i go
see them they're a hard-working band
yeah quite true as you think you'd say
the same thing about judas priest
and um at this point even an older band
like uriah heap who we saw
amazing show you know that's so great to
be here
yeah yeah so so um the other thing that
i think could be
going back to this thing about things
that put bands on hiatus
this would pertain to like earlier on
when metal
became uh you know
a much harder selling you could say so
think about the 90s
um there were you know like the genres
developing but for a lot of the big acts
it was a very lean time for them
and quite a few bands maybe had to say
well this is going to be
it so financial prospects and now in the
time of covet 19 that nobody's quite
sure what's going to happen
either right so some bands that like
iron maiden will always sell out
anywhere where they go same thing with
judas priest other bands that are
that are quite good like raven you know
they had they had to do a kickstarter
for their their last big album
um so they're kind of they're still
struggling even though they really
deserve to
to succeed um if they were to go
on a farewell tour and then come back
when
circumstances have changed financially
medically in terms of banned harmony
maybe there's maybe there's a case to be
made that that would be okay
so like with ozzy osbourne you know he
did the
no more tours when he thought that he
had ms
and so coming back from that maybe
there's maybe there's a case for
it's okay in that in that case right um
now it maybe you only get one shot to do
that
maybe you can't do it indefinitely
um so maybe no more tourist two has to
be the last tour
that makes sense and yeah that's you
know if you if you think
it it's it for you yeah um
you know i i didn't know that actually
you're the one that told me i didn't
know about the no more tours was because
of that
um maybe i knew at the time but i tend
to forget things so
um i think yeah okay so you'll get a
pass on that
similar thing with judas priests in the
epitaph tour right
where rob helford was clearly not doing
well
on the tour was giving it his best but
it wasn't
it wasn't his best at in 2012 is not his
best in 2018
interesting well i don't want to play
monday morning quarterback on this
but they shouldn't they you know they
shouldn't have called it a farewell tour
they should have said it's a special
tour we're going to be playing a
retrospective
and then if another tour doesn't happen
it will come out in the news that rob's
not doing great
yeah i didn't i don't know i mean well
in that i don't know what in effect what
they did
afterwards they said oh well we misspoke
you know it wasn't really a farewell
tour
and now the scorpions let's talk about
them because
they did a farewell tour and and it was
a three-year long tour like all over the
world
you know and then they they decided that
it wasn't a farewell tour after all so
mattias jobs
said that the idea for a scorpion's fair
well tour came from the manager at the
time
he said that every member of the lineup
thought that his bandmates wanted to
retire
it wasn't until they actually got on the
road that they realized that they didn't
want to retire and so they were kind of
suckered into it you might say
and he said we thought it rationally it
might be a good idea to say bye while we
were still in the best shape
leave the scene with the best impression
but seven years later
it still goes as well we still run
around like crazy and we don't look that
much different so we postponed the end
of everything
and now we don't know klaus mind says
in in an interview there were so many
images in our minds and so many emotions
in our hearts everything we experienced
between 2010 and 2012 was so powerful
you stand on stage look down and see so
many fans
including the younger generation who are
really getting into it and saying guys
this is so cool
we're seeing you for the first time when
will you be back
and here's here's the key line it's so
motivating and inspiring to play for
three generations we're having too much
fun to put down the guitars
so klaus mine is saying we realized by
doing the tour
that we weren't ready to say goodbye
that
there's more in us to do now
he's talking as if this is like oh man
it's for the fans you know they're all
like
we we still want to see you you know uh
rock on scorpions
but is it selfish is it is it more like
being the
the you know artist up on stage who's
like my needs my demands
my wishes take priority i think i've
still got something
you know left in me so therefore
i should get to keep doing this you know
it's not really a farewell tour
it's taxi back seas you know i'm
conflicted about this i think on the one
hand
that recognition i think there's
something real there in talking about
man when you look out at this audience
and you see these people having a great
time
and some of them are older people who
know like every line of the songs and
some of them are younger people who are
like
holy crap these old guys rock i want to
see them again
there's something to that but the way
that it's phrased to me
makes it sound a little self-indulgent
what do you think
well you know the self-indulgence comes
from the phrase
farewell tour so oh i think okay so
so the um
you know i don't think it's selfish if a
band wants to go play and do a tour
the selfish part comes in going back to
the monetary thing
um it's our farewell tour here's our
exclusive merch which people like i said
people gonna buy 10 of each
yeah and sell it on ebay and you know so
they're going to rack in the money
so there's a speculation part of it you
could say well yeah i
mean um you know
to say this is a farewell tour you said
it earlier
you don't just decide it when the when
you're rehearsing for the tour
you know you you this is a long plan
this has been
this has been many meetings with the
management the record companies
the how are we going to close out well
we think of the business parts
contract sign how are we going to um
how are we going to close this out and
give you the money how are the future
album sales going to be you know as far
as uh you know who's gonna get money
from that
so you have a lot of you know loose ends
to tie before you go on a farewell tour
um uh you would imagine you know so you
know you have to tell your crew they're
not gonna work anymore
so you're gonna have to um so i think if
you just did a tour
and said you know well i don't know you
know maybe we'll do another album maybe
we won't
but then you decide but we have more to
say that's fine that's great you it's
it's your it's your decision what you do
with your music and your band
i think the big thing is using that
farewell
uh it's well stated fair well tour is a
big marketing thing
right it's it's marketing i mean
um right if you know because like
let's say i i decided um that i'm gonna
stop playing uh my original music
i'm not gonna put posters around boston
and everything
this is scotch rollies farewell tour
because
yeah but who care you know it's kind of
like you know it's not it
yeah well tour is a business uh it's
it's a marketing business plan
um it's kind of like we're going to make
a big deal about this we're going to
have special this and that
and to come back from it i have to say
maybe that's
you know uh you know if they were to do
other projects it doesn't mean they
can't do music anymore so if say iron
maiden did one
but um uh but dave murray
formed a new band that's totally cool
you know
or they all did their own things but we
don't see iron maiden again
yeah there's a there's a point that andy
made a while back that i want to come
back to that i think kind of fits in
here she says
some of the best tours we've seen
whether they were farewell tours or not
included the history of their
storytelling as musicians
especially when the careers spanned over
decades saxon
did this in the smaller performance that
we attended
as a matter of fact that was at the
northern lights
theater here at the pottawatomie casino
and
it was saxons and black star riders
slash thin lizzie right um scott gorham
is there and and they had a they had a
thing before that
um where biff byford
and um scott gorham got up on stage
and answered questions about the band's
password like a little warm-up thing
uh a q a yeah yeah it was quite
impressive
but then saxon did that during their
their
thing they were like well you know
here's here's one from you know
wheels of steel here's one from this
here's one from this you know we were
thinking about this when we did it
and and i think you know when you have a
catalog that
um admits of that you know because
you've done
you know over a dozen studio albums
and gone on a lot of tours um that's
that's something that's that's feasible
i i don't know that every band could
actually
do that right well that's true the
smaller venue the more intimate venue
yeah that's another advantage to it but
i do
like that idea i do like especially you
know
all these bands in the 70s and 80s were
so mysterious that we didn't have
twitter to know what they were doing
every moment circus and hit parader and
carang and stuff like that right and
then you had
the the poster of you know blackie
lawless on your dorm room or something
and you know they were like not they
were not
human to us they were rock stars um
but now years later you know they've
grown older and
more mature in some ways and for them to
kind of say hey you were there with us
and we want to tell you what was going
on
for me i think that's really uh i think
you said blue oyster cult was doing that
too that
eric bloom was telling some stories yeah
again
same same same venue a very small
intimate venue
um that's where you can really do that
sort of thing much much easier i would
say
you know but i do love the story aspect
that's cool
i mean you know like i'm saying like you
know at one time
they were like you know bigger than life
and and now it's kind of like
you know you're in it you're having fun
and then they're like hey
when this album came out i i bought it
the day it came out and i mowed like six
lawns to do it
yeah yeah um anyways anyway
i just thought it was cool well so i
coming back to the
ethics of doing farewell tours i mean i
i personally think that there could be
some reasons to come out of
the farewell post farewell retirement
and start touring again but i think that
the you almost have to like prove your
case
you know you've got to make a case for
why
you deserve to do that and other bands
don't
so the the prima facie view should be
if you've done a farewell tour that's it
for you you know you can reconfigure
as musicians in a different format but
that you you can't just go back out on
on tour you know um
what do you think well um first of all
um can you quickly explain uh
prima facie what is sort of on
on its face sort of like all things
being equal right
so if if uh if you don't have some
overriding reason why you should be
going back out on tour
that other people would accept not just
you but other people who are reasonable
i don't think i don't think ethically
you you get to do that
i mean you can do it like motley crue
does but i mean
and motley crue is an interesting case
because they committed
publicly to saying this is this is bs
you shouldn't be doing this and then
they did it themselves
so i think that you know when we can
actually talk
one of the things we talk about in
ethics are what we call prima facie
duties these are duties that we
generally feel that we owe to other
people
and you know there could be exceptions
but one of these is what we call a duty
of fidelity
that's what w d ross called it and
fidelity means
keeping the promises that you made i
think when you do a farewell tour you're
making a promise
that this is your last tour you know and
it's not just about
taking advantage of people financially i
think that the points that you're making
about that
are dead on but i think even if like
they weren't making a buck off of it it
would still be the wrong thing to do
in most cases because they're breaking a
trust that they've
they've built with their audience
they're exploiting the trust that they
have um in order to do something for
whatever motive they have you know maybe
some of them can't sit at home
and enjoy retirement maybe some of them
need to make more money
maybe with some of them it's an ego
thing they they can't be
who they are without having you know a
million fans in front of them
you know um but those are i mean as
painful as that might be that's kind of
that's those are things that would fall
under self-serving
yeah um but again i don't have a problem
with it if they don't say farewell so
um yeah so i just wanted clarification
on that term
um but i think um it can't be black or
white because
i i agree with you there has to be if
you're going to break that trust
you better have a good um
override yeah override like you know i
guess for
rob halford it's like wait i didn't give
you my best
it's kind of what we're saying
interesting so yeah you know that
that actually i think that could be a
good justification it could be like
the last tour that we did we weren't at
our best we want to give you now
judas priest at its best you know and
here's why i'm in the best
let's say i i i started working out i
got out of a depression
i got a vocal coach i got you know and
you know it wouldn't be a bad idea for
the band to do
one live tune on this uh soundstage
and put it out on social media and go
what do you think
should we go back on tour well you know
because i agree with you
um if uh if
if you've made a promise um
i don't know if yeah you better have
like a really good reason
for um breaking that promise because
people do get mad it's kind of like well
you know you
you know people say another farewell
tour like we said before
i you know some people you know they
weren't coming to my state so
i rented a hotel and i got bought a
flight i went out
and i took a week off of unpaid work
and you know because that this was the
last chance i'd get to see you
you know um and that happens a lot
people buy hotel rooms buy flights
it's not just the 200 ticket or whatever
it is
it's they put their life on hold to be
there
be part of this moment that later became
not
the moment they paid for yeah you know
um
the point that d snyder made about uh
when people do this as a practice
eventually
nobody's going to believe anybody saying
it's a fair well tour
that that's really uh
you know an important point as well and
that connects to what we in ethics we
call the conscience
you know categorical imperative
which says that we should we should only
do things that we can universalize
and by that we mean um do things that we
would say okay
if everybody in the world behaved this
way you know
would we be okay with that would would
things even make sense and consoles
this is from i'm sorry the philosopher
kant yeah manuel kant yeah
okay sorry so so he no no problem he
says um
certain things if we were to like
totally universalize them they
they would there there would be such
illogic such contradiction
that certain institutions wouldn't even
make any sense promises are one of those
if everybody could just like break a
promise whenever they wanted to
and not only could but did then after a
while nobody believed any promises and
you don't have to have everybody doing
it before
you reach a tipping point there's sort
of a so a lot of
ethicists have said hey it never happens
that way but you can say
pragmatically you can reach a tipping
point where
the trust is gone not just trust in one
band or
one person trust across the board where
we would reach the point where you know
somebody would be like this is our
farewell tour and everyone's like yeah
right whatever you're not doing a real
farewell tour we don't know if
it is or not when you reach that tipping
point you're you're in trouble
and the financial incentives
of doing farewell tours are going to not
pay off
when they do that because people be like
i don't know
maybe they'll be back next year i'm not
going to buy the tickets i'm not going
to do the
elaborate planning required for that
so i think that snyder's on to a really
important point
with that i just want to with with that
theory i like it so
if i'm in a community of people and i
said i'm gonna be
the one that acts out i'm gonna slash
some tires i'm gonna
and i guess what point is well if you're
okay with everybody doing that
yeah and then we wouldn't have a small
society we wouldn't function
and i guess it's not fair to say to kant
it's not fair to say well that would
never happen because i don't think
that's his point i think it's a moral
barometer if i'm
correct i think it's kind of uh think
before you do it like
just because i can get away with it what
if would you be okay if everyone else
did it and if your answer is no
so um yeah but yeah i like that tipping
point where it's kind of like
i'm not gonna break plans i already
already saw them
um and i mean that would be my take on
it but
obviously people will you know kiss
could do as many tours as they want
people to buy
tickets even if paul stanley's in a
wheelchair i feel like it's just
they have that kind of die hard can you
imagine them coming out on rascals
[Laughter]
i can but this that's really interesting
i'm i'm learning a lot this is good
yeah um you know another thing that we
can talk about
um actually before we do that let's
let's take mark's question here that i
think it's kind of good
do you owe your audience a farewell tour
isn't just suddenly deciding that you're
no longer touring in some way also
unfair to your audience so like
you get to the end of a tour and you're
like man that tour really took it out of
us
i'm done man that that's it we're we're
no longer doing tours
uh and then everyone who didn't buy a
ticket because they didn't know it was
the last tour would be like oh
i missed them now i'm never gonna get to
see them you know
i think you know
my my point i kind of think
um you don't actually
have you don't actually owe it to say
this is a farewell to her
i don't yeah i don't think so because
well
you know you could finish the tour and
something can come up and that's your
last
and you didn't know it um but again
making the conscious decision
deliberating over it
and then going on and saying this is the
big bang out here and then going
ah i'm bored or you know
let's just go out let's make some more
money or you know you have an expensive
life
habit it you bought too many motorcycles
too many cars
i wonder though if if there isn't
another issue that's raised by mark's
question
do musicians that have a large fan base
do they kind of owe a certain
transparency
to their audience about like how they're
doing physically how they're
how they're doing um mentally you know
so like if you knew that
that somebody is touring and they're
sick
right and and that they're you know
they're
this is this is probably going to be
their farewell tour because they've got
a diagnosis that they're going to be
gone in a year
um they probably should disclose that
i mean i mean here we run into things
we're like you could say well no no
that's their private life they get to
keep that to themselves i don't know
it's hard to keep things
under wrap you know in 2020. i mean
maybe in 1980
you can quietly do that but um you just
need one
um you need eddie trunk to raise
you know is so so and you know if the
fans speculate it's a final tour and you
don't announce it as such
you know it might be like hey greg you
know let's go see this band because
this might be their last one but if they
went get another one we wouldn't feel
betrayed because they never said this is
our last one
uh either we were misinformed or the
problem
uh fixed itself yeah you know you know
like the thing with alfred is a great
example of
you know i want to give my fans money's
worth we'll give it one more time but
wait you know wait now we're going to
give you
some money because like i saw them what
two nights before you or after you like
a few years ago
okay um and it was unbelievable i mean
it was i was jumping up and down going
crazy it was a great show
um mark has a follow-up that i think is
this
this
is a good one um if you decide that the
next tour is your final tour
should you tell your audience so you
mean on the
before your second to last tour no
you're deciding
for you're deciding before you go on
tour you've got like a whole tour
planned out and then you're like
listen guys um let's have a band meeting
is this going to be our last tour and
then everybody in the band is like
man i'm so glad you asked that because
i'm tired of this you know i want to
i want to like enjoy myself in my last
10 to 20 years of life
um if you know that that's going to be
your last tour do you have a duty to
to announce it as a farewell to her
you know let me let me kind of
dig a little before that you don't know
it's your last tour you're tired at the
moment
you know i mean maybe what you need is
two years off and then
recharge your batteries and you're ready
um
and maybe that's what we're seeing oh
god i can't do another day of this
but then two years later something
happened you met a new partner you got
out of a
uh a toxic marriage um you gotta take
care of yourself and you're
so um there should be some thought of
like you know it's kind of like wedding
vows so of course you can get divorced
yeah but um you better think of those
and take them seriously
um i kind of think if there's medical
stuff involved
you probably you and you know that it's
going to preclude you from
continuing you probably should make that
your fair wall store
that doesn't necessarily mean the whole
band has to it really depends on the
band so like with with lemmy
um you know he is motorhead
and now mickey d's with the scorpions
now
and i'm not sure where the guitar went
off to
but um and they they made a decision
we're not trying to continue motorhead
without lemmy this
that would be ridiculous uh which is the
right call
um and and i think it was it was fairly
quick what happened with him um
dio is another prime example you know
and with dio
there i was i was wondering if we should
include this
that idea of having dio's hologram
and then um the members of the band
playing um
[Music]
you know i i i like dio and i like i
like wendy
dio but i think that was a bad decision
on
on their part and and i can understand
besides the financial things and besides
that i
i wonder if we could pull this off you
know the idea of like
appealing to the fans is a good good one
you know we're going to give you one
more chance to be there
but they didn't i don't know i don't
think they had his consent
to do that maybe they did maybe he maybe
had a conversation
you know i i think i hate the idea
because part of it
what's that of holograms well yeah
because let's say you buy a front row
ticket
you know to get to get deal to give you
a high five in real
life or to get you know you're screaming
along with the lyrics of deal to point
to you
yeah you know and be part of the the
aesthetic energies of uh
of uh the the energy of the room
right so part of that is well if geo's
not really there
he's not feeding off the room this is
the exact same way he acted
in philadelphia the exact way he acted
in texas
and so now what you're not you're
missing the live experience of
um even if the setlist is going to be
the same something happened to everybody
that day where the performance
is either i've seen dios band pretty
good and i've seen them mind blowingly
on fire and
um if you have dio playing the same
singing the exact same way saying the
same rants everywhere
you're not having the live experience
you might as well buy the let me push
this a little bit then so imagine that
we've got
you know a really super powered ai
and they've got tons and tons of do
footage so they can have an effective
hologram that can respond spontaneously
to say the crowd and like you know point
to the to the guy in the front row
you know obviously you can't like you
know give him a high five because you
can't touch or anything like that
but it can respond spontaneously and it
can
it can to some degree feed off the band
you know
and and do things like come up with new
new um between song stories or something
like that
you know well no would that be that
would that be
would that be okay no i mean well
well i i shouldn't say no that's um for
i should say in my opinion you're still
not dealing with
a breathing human that um has human
emotions
had uh maybe they had a little bit too
much to drink the night
before so a little hungover so it's
going to be a little different these are
all moments
or you know um they slept really well
and or the band had they had a fight
with deal or they got along and had a
moment
and all of a sudden there's connection
on stage um that you're still
not a a hologram is pointing at you it's
not dio
yeah um so you can i mean we could do
this with
computer you know you could get um you
know like uh
one of those back then they were trying
to do in the 80s they were trying to do
those
um uh a uh
ai uh you you would talk to them in text
and they would respond based off of
we weren't talking to a real person and
it's just my thing i mean
i you know it's just like the kiss thing
you're not seeing paul and
and um gene and
you're not here that maybe kiss will
make their franchise a hologram affair
eventually i think there's probably no
good chance that they would do that you
know
but to me they might as well do a laser
show that tours
like you know those um uh you go into
the one of those called
um wow where's my brain
you know where you um you go down and
it's a dome and there's like lasers and
there's
like in a planetarium yeah yeah might as
well do a
kiss planetarium show with paul stanley
from back in the day
and um that that all the masks you know
like swooping around the sky
that would be cool because that's a
that's appropriate that's the show
it's not you're not buying a ticket to
pretend you're experiencing
a kid's show um you know and i don't
care if somebody's going to be hired to
do paul steele that's
not it's not paul stanley doing the
rants
um you know i don't think there's an
item
that kiss hasn't been willing to stamp
their name and faces on
at one point in time over their career
and there isn't
there isn't anything uh you know media
wise
that's too cheesy for kiss to appear in
you know if you've ever seen like
uh the scooby-doo things where kiss
shows up or the
the uh thing where they're they're in
the uh amusement park i forget what's
gonna be
the phantom of the park that's right
i own that we were we were so excited
when i was kids
we were kids to see that because it was
kiss right and
we ignored the fact that it was such a
terrible movie
i know and they say it they didn't even
know what they were doing
my favorite is when they're like in full
makeup and they're like suntanning by
the pool
yeah like the big boots and everything
yeah yeah
um but i don't know i maybe maybe i'm in
the
the minimum i mean like part of the live
experience and pay for a ticket
is the energy of the crowd you know um
you know and and kind of like the band
responding to the energy of the crowd
um based off of what happened to the you
know like for me
um performance live performance versus
live album is a very different thing and
that's what motivates me to buy a ticket
to be part of the experience
if it's a computerized experience it's
not
uh people argue this all the time
we should just have ai write all the
music because nobody will know the
difference
and um you know they want to you know
take uh you know
there's nothing computers they'll be
able to do everything in 20 years we
won't need people well
what of course we need we need people
what happened to the
human element i mean you can yeah the
best i mean the best you can do is
program a computer to do what we can
already do
we can already compose i can compose
like voc i can rip him off
and do his things you don't need a
computer to do that you don't need a
computer
i the the the deep is it called deep
thought or the
the ai that was doing visual stuff that
google came
out with it made um
it made very interesting compositions
they all kind of looked the same
and they were all kind of creepy too
like they had a penchant for putting
eyes in all sorts of places doing things
that
probably humans wouldn't do and so it
did create something that was
arguably new but it wasn't something
that was arguably good
so maybe you know computers could do
some of this
but but my question is why humans do
that we
we invent you know we we create we
evolve
i mean look if you look at music history
if you look at art history
it was until the french impressionists
that we had modern
art or modern music with debbie and
revell and leave nepal
i mean i think that the the reasons why
people would do it some of it would be
financial because
when you have ai's whoever owns the ais
owns the stuff right so you can make
money by having your ai's doing things
but i think there's also this impetus to
see well can we do it with ais right
there's this curiosity on the part of of
people that drives things forward and
it's
it's similar to the curiosity that that
says man what if i do this with my
guitar
over by the speakers can i get a strike
you know sound out of it
it's the same drive but it's being used
in in different ways
mark says do you see the did you see the
ai developed to finish
schubert's unfinished symphony um think
we'll ever have something like that with
naomi's box of unfinished riffs they
then they tour
that as black sabbath 50 years from now
with holograms
i haven't seen that but i mean that's
the sort of thing that we're talking
about
i will say this i've seen a description
of the
um doom metal band orchid
as the band that
made all the songs that black sabbath
didn't make
because they they got like a really
close
the singer is not is not exactly ozzie i
actually like the singer quite a bit
but the you know the bassist could very
well be geezer butler
the guitarist could very well be tony
the way that this stuff sounds so we
we've already got humans
kind of doing that you know um
go ahead i want to respond um
so the ai development to finish
schubert's unfinished symphony we don't
need
ai to do that um we know schubert's
tendencies we know what he
his his rules he developed um any good
composer
you know i i would probably i would
probably end it with like a da
da da da da da da da da da da
you could do it you know well i i mean
like just take a really good composer i
mean
um i i did i do have a background in
classical composition
it's not really what i do i um i compose
but you get any
any great and you you know it's like i
said i could
you know like here i've studied these my
whole life
right and i i went through a time where
i wrote bach
like i took the progression see outlined
you don't need ai to do it
so my question is why you have an ai
doing something a human could probably
do better
um because uh
you know there's the argument of what's
better yeah yeah but uh
but any of these things you know i could
i maybe you and i could finish black
sabbath riffs because
we know what a black sabbath riff sounds
like yeah
but some things are better left undone
why
finish it you know this is it's kind of
like are we going to take the
partially burned aristotle scrolls i
mean i don't know if there are any
and we're going to have a i say this is
what
aristotle would have would have written
next i mean what would you say to that
that can't happen well yeah i mean
we don't have we don't have those those
scrolls um we do have some
screwed up scrolls from other thinkers
and i suppose you could you could do
that but it would be gobbledygook most
likely you know um i don't know that it
would actually be
something but go ahead
but scholars wouldn't take seriously
would they
no i don't think so um and that's that's
that's what's going on so i mean that's
a really interesting parallel
should musicians take take seriously
what ai
musicians and quotes are are doing
you know well i'll tell you why not is
because
for ai to work we have to feed in
human thinking right so
for ai to finish um schubert
you got to feed him yeah you have to we
have to put in what we know about
schubert for it to do it
yeah yeah and why go that extra step
when we could just sit down and
and say it might go something like this
you know
um but we'll never know what it really
you know i'm thinking
leave it go leave it alone there's
nothing i'm not sure
about this we're starting to get this
discussion about farewell tours and
stuff but
why are we prolonging what's what's
wrong with
you know we get like a bach hologram and
we think we're seeing bach perform in
17 with the harpsichord
no it's kind of funny if you think about
this
we're joking about super groups at the
beginning of this
if we're gonna do this we could have
like all these modules and they could be
like okay so we've got
tony oh me over here like recently there
was a thing
on um on
uh twitter it was a challenge
put together you know your your super
group with these four players and i was
thinking four it probably isn't enough
because
you know not for a metal band you
probably need two guitarists or a
guitarist and a an organist
although you could do power trios and
stuff like that and i was thinking like
who are my favorite people
and uh you know obviously like lemmy and
dio
would be cool to bring together and
maybe steve harris as well but lemmy's
already playing bass so i don't know
you know but let me could i guess kind
of play his bass like a rhythm guitar
and then
what guitarist do you bring in and now
you're done now you don't have a drummer
you know
and and so um but but imagine you could
do that
and like you've got like the steve
harris cartridge
right and you've got the i don't know uh
paul stanley cartridge or whatever and
you just you just plunk them all
in and you're like there you go super
group and the ai is set up in such a way
that their egos
you know are tamped down maybe in the
settings and they won't like you know
fail to cooperate with each other and
then you're like so what would it be
like if um
this you know these people were all
playing together
well maybe that's feasible down the line
i i don't know
would it would it actually be you know
good music
we'd have to experiment and find out
ai can never do it because sometimes you
know you don't know all there's too many
variables that ai
miss you know for example you walk in
the room and somebody rubs you the wrong
way
just instantly now ai's not going to
have that variable because
nobody knows that and the the people
don't know it when they get together
now something that ai can't do that
you're
you're familiar with and i i've done it
as well
when you make a mistake in a song that
you're playing
and you recover from the mistake in such
a way
that you like get back into whatever
you're supposed to be doing
and you introduce something new
it's sort of like like falling off
balance and then catching yourself in
just the right way where you push the
button that you're supposed to push
yeah there's nothing wrong with mistakes
there's and sometimes that's part of the
performance
you know but an ai can't can't
effectively do that but then people
argue well
you know like i remember when drum
machines came out we all argued the the
human feel went oh we'll make them make
mistakes
well that's not the point it's not
that's not that's
making mistakes is not humanizing it
well it's not making mistakes though
it's introducing
a certain new algorithm which isn't
making a mistake but it's supposed to
sound like making a mistake
i think right but it's not it's not
organic yeah it's like
and you know if i go up with um
segue up with a three other guitar
players and we all make mistakes we're
gonna
recover in entirely unique ways yeah um
so
i mean again i mean a lot of people are
very ai
you know and i just say why you know and
it's like you know
for one you go ahead you know it's like
you go to the bank now it's like oh you
that's all online well i'm talking to
you now
and you cannot can you not help me
resolve this issue well i don't have
that go online
so you're saying that you want your job
replaced
by you know um so it's you know i i
don't understand the appeal of ai rather
than i mean i do understand the
curiosity
and it could be kind of cool and
interesting but uh
the super group thing you'd never know
from ai i mean it could give you
something
that comes out but there's too many
variables that even the people would
never know because
you get them in a room they could start
talking about politics and get in a
fight or they could start
talk about politics and really unite or
it could be something
outside of the music or maybe they can't
adapt to their time together and there's
no way you could program that in because
you know how paul stanley for example
would do his rhythm guitar with us with
with nico mcbrain
they'd have to work it out somehow and
you never know how it
there's way too many many people
oversimplify
um what this is you really we're pouring
rules into a computer
that we can do ourselves so the computer
can do it yeah
anyways i i i do have strong feelings
about ai so
it's kind of like no i think it's a very
interesting topic
to to go into i'm coming back to the
um farewell tours i think one of the
the points in terms of ethics that i
i wanted to draw out a little bit more
um we can talk about moral theories like
virtue ethics
or you know we talked about some
deontological ethics
um capturing that relationship between
the band
and the audience that has been built up
over time
and comes with as i think d snyder's is
you know
rightly pointing out comes with some
not just obligations but something that
has to do with the very structure
of the relationship
it's something that you use that word
organically it's grown organically over
time if a band has been
giving out you know music by
issuing albums and going out on tours
for 40 years
that's that's something new has happened
in that i mean that's that's two
generations
and the scorpion's talking about looking
out in the audience and seeing three
generations
out there um i think that that
that fan um
banned relationship is something that
some bands play
fast and loose with and other bands
take more seriously and and you can you
can like be pretending to take it
seriously when you come on stage and
you're like hello
milwaukee you know and you you don't
have no idea where the hell you are
you've just been fed
our favorite place to play exactly right
but i think there's
i think there's um there's something
there and this has to do with the ethics
of
farewell tours that says that you you
really have to take
you've you've earned this trust through
hard work
and all the things that you've done and
probably making some mistakes and then
recovering from them later on you've
earned this trust from at least some of
your audience who are the devoted fans
you you really do owe something to them
in terms of
truthfulness and thinking things through
and not
abusing that trust and i think that's
part of what dee snyder was
was articulating in his uh his comments
so it's
it's going beyond just like rules or you
know duties
to to talking about a relationship and
ongoing
the key thing you said thinking things
through
okay and i think that's key because
i like your example earlier it's kind of
like i'm tired i can't do this
anymore if you really thought it through
you might say well instead of a farewell
tour
why don't i just unburn out for two
years and see if i feel like making
we feel like making a record yeah you
know we're still kind of young we're in
our 50s kind of thing
or whatever and um you know that
i guess if they thought it through
that's a key
to me that's key i'm sorry that's a
that's a key thing because you know
uh you should have lived life long
enough to know that your mind can change
in
a month after the tour like you know i'm
bored
yeah so this is a good thing to kind of
go out on and bring this to a close
do you think that part of the reason why
some bands don't do that
is because they're more driven by their
egos
as being rock stars so like you know
when motley crue signs
in agreement with each other saying
we're not going to do any more tours
it's not only about like okay we're
going to really get a lot of merch money
out of this tour because everyone knows
it
it it's also like a way of declaring
yourself in
a rather outspoken bombastic way that i
think kind of fits in with
who motley crew were when d snyder and
the twisted sister guys say we're this
is it
and they're doing it in a more
prudential way i think it's less about
although i mean not not to say that you
know the twisted sister guys aren't
larger than life right
but i think they're doing it in a
different in a different manner
so maybe personalities play
an important role in this you know some
people are more thoughtful than others
you know actually that's a really good
that's a great point and
we'd have to take um you know we'd have
to know these people
i mean i guess we if we had if you and i
knew all these people personally we can
say well
so and so is is in it for him or herself
yeah um you take someone like dora
who is amazing to her fans and um
i saw her a couple years ago and she was
sick
she waited for three hours and took a
picture with every single person
at the show and um she's always been
really good
fans um and i think she's someone that
is not gonna pull uh this is my favorite
and come back
um and it's hard for her to get this
country you know it's hard enough for
her to get here but
you know i guess what you know what you
see is a fan on how
people treat the fans i know some people
that have
oh sorry go ahead i'll tell you a story
that's kind of funny about kiss so we we
saw them at live at letterman
because we were part of the kiss army so
we we got the tickets we went down to
the city
and and uh in new york it's hard to get
out of a venue
without without encountering some fans
because of just the way places are set
up
so after the show back doors yeah andy
was like hey do you want to go see
you know the back door area and i was
like sure and and so we go back there
and three members of the band came out
and like signed autographs and you know
uh
you know did all sorts of like talking
with people and that was really cool
paul stanley was one of them the one guy
who like had a towel over his head
went straight to the limo um and
wouldn't like talk to anybody gene
simmons he was out of there
but all the rest of the van hung around
not for an inordinate amount of time but
at least for a little bit
i heard a story about gene simmons and i
don't know who told me
they were in an elevator with gene
simmons going down and he was ready to
do
one of his meet and greets and whoever
told me said um you know hey
do you mind if i get a picture with you
i don't mean to bother you and he goes
no
no i won't get a picture with you now he
thought gene was being a jerk but on the
other hand
he's ready to walk out for people that
paid two hundred dollars to take a
picture with
he doesn't want to cheap and cheap in
the brand so to speak keeping the brand
but that's interesting
and that happened with like um night
ranger
so everybody in the band is hanging out
after
and jack blades is nowhere to be seen
and eventually
an hour later he comes out with a towel
over his head with escorts and
pushes through people it's like yeah you
can't say hi to people that bought all
your records and
everybody else in the band is fine by it
but um you know he
he did his meet and greet earlier so um
so let's let's take mark's last point
and then we'll bring this to a close to
go back to the transparency point
that's crucial to the relationship
social media at least allows
more of that now than in the past but
that comes out with
more responsibility for the bands
yeah i think we are in a different era
because of that um that's that's
completely right and
you know you mentioned like let's say
that person is like
i'm taking a selfie anyway that would be
feasible to do
you know and you could he could be even
like streaming on facebook live and you
know it shows
jeans and struggling for the phone and
now you've got a story right
so yeah well
i want to point out something kind of
crucial that
i know we're coming to a close but in
1985 when we were seeing the bands
all these bands rock and roll was only
20 years old 21 years old
so there's no bands retiring unless you
know even
even the stones were young in 85 still i
mean you know
95 now where we are now we are in the
first
era now of bands being really old
um this is probably the first time in
history where
rock and roll has existed long enough
that you know this is an issue this
wasn't an issue in 1980
you think it's been uh 16 years since
the beatles were on the ed sullivan show
so um so 16 years of rock and roll
rock and roll deep purple in 1970
that band was only 14 years old by the
point um
so i guess we could say we're in any era
for this discussion
yeah and that that was the point that uh
to bring it back
to the start i think that was the point
that um
vinnie apiece long time veteran of all
this stuff
was making he said i don't think anyone
thought this music was going to last
this long so
absolutely all right well this has been
a great conversation
as always and we don't thank you so much
you